does every screenwriter need an agent or
a manager you do if you're not gonna
produce your work independently and
you're gonna try and get it sold and get
it get it produced by someone else it's
pretty hard to do it without that unless
you have a very close friend or relative
who's a producer or you know in a
position to kind of Greenland a movie
but for the most part all writers that
work in the industry have an agent
and/or manager although right now
writers have kind of fired their agents
because of big dispute that the Writers
Guild is having with the agencies as a
whole but putting that aside most
successful writers these days have both
some have only one or the other but
those people are your way of getting
your work to the potential buyers it's
really difficult to do that on one's own
[Music]
you know almost impossible really to to
launch a writing career where you never
had an agent or a manager that's being
the person that introduces you to those
people that rely on them to filter out
all of the people that aren't worthy of
their time so to speak in terms of their
work and their writing so you know the
industry relies on those representatives
to some extent to recommend writers and
scripts and projects and pitches to them
and they'll only be interested if
they're it comes to them recommended by
someone they trust just because there's
a volume of stuff out there that it's
hard for them to sift through all of it
the producers the executives etc without
somebody who's sort of performing that
function for them so in a way that's
what agents and managers do they also
help writers figure out what to write
and how to write and present material
that will be successful as well in
theory so that's a that's a valuable
function as well but the main function
is helping them get work and then
negotiating their their deals and the
business side of their careers and
maximizing that as well which most of us
writers wouldn't be so good at doing
that for ourselves what's your advice to
a screenwriter who doesn't have an agent
in two parts how should they find one
and what should they be doing in the
meantime when there's no active leads so
there's no real easy or direct or
obvious way for a writer to get an agent
or a manager it's what every writer
wants once they recognize that that's
the first step to having a career or to
working professionally pretty much
everyone knows that's what they need but
it's very hard to get one and you can't
just go make that happen so it's more
that you have to like focus on the craft
and focused on the writing it's not so
much how do I get an agent or manager
it's how do I write something that an
agent or manager would like if they read
it that's the key thing that people you
know our best to focus on I think so you
can send query emails to some managers
and even some agents here's a logline of
a script I've written you don't know me
but do you want to read the script and
in theory that could get read and they
could say yes and then they could love
the script and there are a small number
of people that get signed that way very
small I would say but it does happen a
lot of places really legit bigger
management and agency agent companies
won't take those kind of unsolicited
queries won't ever respond to you et
cetera there's also the writing contests
competitions and fellowships and things
and some film festivals have writing
contests that if you do really well at
really prestigious ones there will be
some agents or managers that will
probably find you from that or you can
use that information to make a query
have a better chance that resulting in
them wanting to read something if you
say this was fifth in the Nicholl
fellowship last year obviously that's
gonna help but as far as what to do in
the meantime it's right I mean that's
your job is the writing not think of the
business side and all that stuff the
business side that you can't really
control or force into existence so it's
write and get feedback and be open and
learn and study the craft and keep
writing and write lots of things don't
just spend a million years on one thing
but keep initiating new projects and
exploring new ideas and increasing your
understanding of the craft and sharing
your work with people that can give you
professional level feedback if possible
whether you're in a writing program or
hire a private consultant of some kind
or happen to know somebody that can give
you that that will be honest and helpful
as opposed to just like a friend who
doesn't really know what they're reading
and isn't gonna be nice so to speak
where is someone finding the contact
info for these agents or managers IMDB
Pro yeah I mean you could find when I'm
DB Pro but there's so many companies is
a little hard to sift through and know
which ones are which which ones are
legit which ones are big and which ones
are small I did a list of managers
that's available on my website it's been
like almost three years now it's
probably still mostly up-to-date I've
seen other websites that have you know a
list of the top Hollywood management
companies and so forth so once you know
which ones are the legit ones then you
go to item DB Pro to find their contact
info in theory another way to know who's
legit is if you and this is how I
created my list partly is to read read
information about what spec scripts have
sold in a given year and which managers
represented those or which scripts made
the blacklist or made some of these
other big year-end lists of screenplays
that you can find online and who are the
managers of those agents and those
scripts that will tell you that that's
probably a fairly widget manager become
because if you just search managers on
IMDB Pro you're gonna get thousands and
most of them are not really in a
position probably to be necessarily that
helpful and the same thing with agencies
the writers guild on their website has a
list of franchised writers guild
agencies which right now is a shorter
list because you know there's been this
this standoff negotiation where where
most of the big agencies including the
four big ones that represent 80% of
working writers or something like that
writers aren't dealing with them right
now and everyone said to like fire their
agents so probably many people would
tell you that you really want to be
before this whole dispute happen and
maybe after it's over the big four are
the ones that have the most power and
some most writers gravitate to one of
those big four but there are a lot of
other smaller ones as well some of which
are very legit and many of which are
probably not really going to be able to
do much for you necessarily so part of
it is knowing which ones are
legit ones and then how do I contact
them can I contact them but the bigger
point is realizing that you probably
can't do that much to force your way
into having a manager or an agent it
will sort of happen over time if and
when your work gets to the point where
it's being loved by the kind of people
that that read for the agencies in the
management company there's Mosley's
coverage services online like spec
scout.com is a pretty good one where
these professional readers read and
evaluate scripts and if one does really
well the blacklist has a thing like this
too it goes up on their website and in
theory managers and agents can see it
but again the step is writing something
that the big contest and these kind of
services and professionals would love
first that's the really hard part that
most writers never get to the getting a
manager an agent once you've done that
is easy it's just really hard to get
yourself to that place so that's kind of
the less lesser of Evil's that's the
least of the writers problem the the
real problem is getting your work out
there and getting it good enough so that
somebody you have more than just one
option yeah the real challenge is
getting it good enough good is a
obviously a subjective thing but good
enough in the eyes of those kind people
that's why I say write some of those
people would love if they read it
meaning managers or agents that's the
hard part not the getting it to them
once you've done it because if you've
written something those people would
love it's probably winning contests and
doing well on coverage services and you
probably already have friends that are
agents or friends I mean it's because
it's rare that people get to that level
and when they do they're probably
already on the insider like it's it's
sort of like the next logical step as
opposed to this reaching for this star
thing that you can't even fathom how to
get there it's rare that a writer would
have material that they would love if
you could get it to them but they have
no idea and it just seems impossible
it's usually you would have learned and
educated yourself by osmosis even about
all of that while writing if your
material was at the point where those
people would like it if they'd read it
which is why most of them will say don't
try to find us we'll find you
essentially
you